With the support that I'm getting from
people all around the world, I can say
that I was at least able to have one
meal throughout my day when people were
literally starving from hunger.
And the fact that I have this platform
helped me not only like help myself and
my family, but also like help those who
really need it. You have like no idea
how this is. So you know like uh when
when a like when a bomb would happen
would drop.
>> Guys before the video starts brother and
sisters one um is working in Pakistan
with the floods that's hit the country.
1,700 people have lost their life.
Millions of people have lost their homes
and been displaced. So the videos that
you can see here, the pictures that you
can see guys is demonstrating what one
um is doing on the ground. We know Gaza
is important and we know what's going on
there. But brothers and sisters, we
cannot enable and turn a blind eye to
the suffering of Muslims in different
countries. Be it Pakistan, be it Turkey,
the earthquakes, wherever it may be,
Afghanistan, so many other places need
our help. And I know all of us have
given as much as we can to Gaza. But
brothers and sisters, wall, just imagine
your home wrecked. Thousands of people
have died. Your family members have
passed away. You have nowhere to live.
Brothers and sisters, they need our help
as much as Gaza does. So I urge you
guys, inshallah, it's 100% donation
policy. donate whatever amount even if
it's one pound. The prophet peace be
upon him said the best form of sodak is
to give water. Brothers and sisters,
let's give them food and shelter and
water to drink so they can overcome this
tragedy. Inshallah, I urge you guys to
go to the link and donate now. Enjoy the
video. Asalam alalaykum brothers and
sisters and dear friends. Subhan Allah.
I came across this video of an
individual called Bradley Martin. I've
seen him here and there etc. But I don't
know much about him. But I have to
admire the fact that he was connecting
with someone in Palestine in Gaza. And
we're going to watch the video
inshallah. And we can see moments of
maybe a tear dropping from his eye uh
and him trying not to get emotional.
Subhan Allah. But this is the reality of
what they live in Braum sisters. And
subhan Allah, the prophet told us do not
look at those who do not have who have
what you don't have and be ungrateful to
Allah. Rather look at those who do not
have what you have and be grateful to
Allah subhanaa tala. Look at this
brother in Gaza and look at what he had
to say that brought Bradley nearly to
tears. Let's watch it for oursel.
>> Well, man, it's like the interesting
thing is I don't even want to say at
least. It's such a weird weird position
to be in, but you for sure will probably
never ever go through something harder
than what you're going through right
now.
And
>> I can't imagine. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I think you know
when you make it out of this I think
every single other challenge in your
life will feel very very small.
>> Very small.
>> Like you put it like
>> Yeah. You you hit the nail on the head,
man. Like
>> Yeah.
>> You know when when I think about like my
life when this is all over when I get
back to some kind of normal life because
honestly like when I think about it
right now what what I need is that I
would have a stable source of
electricity. A stable source of
internet, a stable source of food, and
some sense of safety. That is all I'm
asking for.
>> Yeah, that is the mo that is the most
basic
human ever.
>> Yeah. Like I'm telling you when I
>> Subhan Allah. If you just look at that
guys, wah it's I mean the prophetam said
the best form of saddaka is to give
water. It's the basic human right to
have security,
to have food, to have water, to feel
safe, you know, to have a house. These
are the basic things that Allah subhana
t gives people and the human being, the
creator has given sufficient enough for
it to be enough for everyone these
things. But it is the creation that is
stopping that. When people come and say
you know oh why does God no no no no God
has given all the things that you can
make a house have food shelter whatever
it is for that matter but it is the evil
creation that is stopping subhan Allah
that from reaching these innocent people
subhan Allah let's carry on I hope you
guys enjoy the video guys but before
that please download the salah pro app
brothers and sisters we are a charity
all of our services on the app is for
free kibla finder no ads free salah
reminders encourages to pray tells you
salah times you can book a salah
instructor a Quran instructor You can
order a guided prayer map for absolutely
free if you want to learn how to pray
salah. Videos on how to pray salah.
Salah hubs and many many more broken
sisters. We are not an app that shares
your information with third parties. All
of our services on the app is for free.
Download it now inshallah and enjoy it.
Guys, let's go back to the video.
>> When I think about my life before this
all started, I'm like, bro, what was I
even complaining about back then? Like,
bro, I had chicken. I had oats. I had I
had a gym to work out in. I had like I
was safe in my house. I would go out
like at 12:00 a.m. like in the middle of
the night to go to the gym and hit like
a night session and that would be
completely fine. There would be like not
a single problem. My phone would be
charged. I would have internet. I would
be able to text whoever I want.
>> I honestly have no idea what problems I
had back then.
>> Subhan Allah, brothers and sisters. And
this is why, you know, sometimes people
come and say, um, why does this happen?
Why does it happen? It's called the
problem of evil. People come and say,
why does bad things happen? Etc.
Brothers and sisters, bad things happen
because if you don't see ugly, you will
never know what beautiful is. And for
our brothers and sisters in Gaza, like
subhan Allah, they are going through and
and if you think about it, this is why a
toed the oneness of Allah is so
important because if you think about it,
it is humanly impossible for them to go
through what they're going through. And
this man to be smiling, he's look look
at this brother, he's smiling. And it's
an impossibility. It only comes from
Allah. This is why so many people are
flocking to Islam in our da tables. The
hundreds, thousands. Why? Because they
cannot grasp. How can it be? You go
through such turmoil and you still say
alhamdulillah.
Praise be to God. How how does that
work? It's supernatural.
It's supernatural. And subhan Allah. And
that's why Allah subhanaa t test his
servants to bring them closer. And
that's why I've never seen many people.
Yes, a calamity is what that makes them
appreciate. They complain about this and
all of us are like this blame worthy of
this. We complain about things
other people would die to have. We
complain about stupid things. That's why
I try my best. Wah I ask Allah's
forgiveness every day for my ingratitude
every day. Oh Allah forgive me. Allah
what an ungrateful man I am. How
ungrateful I am to you. Yes, you give me
so much and I carry on sinning. But
let's carry on inshallah. Subhan Allah.
He he even comes that realization. But
let's watch inshallah
>> like, "Oh my my university is getting
too uh too like I'm I'm having too much
stress and pressure in my university."
Bro, just man up. Okay. Like that is
really not that much pressure as much as
you think it is. Okay.
>> Yeah. Cuz that's for damn sure.
So I mean
it's such a sad thing but there's
there's a little bit of silver lining
maybe.
I mean, okay, like I would say the
silver line here is going to be the fact
that right now I am much luckier than a
lot of people. Like, you know, I have a
platform. I have a fundraiser that
people can support me on. I have like I
would say with the support that I'm
getting like,
>> by the way, we're going to put that in
the the link in the description right
now. So, if you guys want to support, go
there right now and do it. Do it right
now.
>> I mean, look, the fact that Bradley is
doing this, he could get cancelled. He
can like, you know, like DJ Khaled, uh,
that flipping obese sellout. Yes,
flipping obese sellout. Um, this guy
makes me sick, bro. This guy makes me
sick. He, you know,
this guy is there and he's giving him a
platform, sharing his link so he can
have some, you know, some donations or
whatever it is for that matter. Subhan
Allah. And in the beginning of this
video, guys, National Wak forever,
sorry, is also working very hard for the
Palestinian cause. Alhamdulillah. It's a
work that it's ongoing charity. Please
donate to that as well. I have to
applaud Bradley on this.
>> Yeah, really appreciate it, man. Thank
you so much.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Uh so, you know, like with the support
that I'm getting from people all around
the world, I can say that I was at least
able to have one meal throughout my day
when people were literally starving from
hunger.
And the fact that I have this platform
helped me not only like help myself and
my family but also like help those who
really need it. You have like no idea
how this is. So you know like uh when
when a like when a bomb would happen
would drop
>> I think that is where I think he kind of
got into a bit of a tear as you can see
bro sisters and you know as men we hold
it back especially if you're a man uh
that's you know quite hench like that
you know you know some don't want to
show weaknesses but you can see he's
he's in he's in tears
>> you would hear like the sound of it
falling and then like the impact
but in in this one like there was no
falling sound like straight into the
impact. that.
>> So,
>> because it was so close.
>> Yeah, because it was so close. Like, I'm
telling you, I opened my house's door
>> and I just saw dust. Like, I didn't see
like anything in front of me. I didn't
see the street. I didn't see the wall
that we have in front of the house. I
just saw dust. That was what it was. Um,
so it would have like, you know, thick
like iron wires inside.
>> Yeah.
>> And after that, like we would, you know,
use the cement. We would put like the
concrete over it. So, uh, yeah, that
part was the the destroyed part of my
house.
>> Did you ever did you ever pick up the
rubbles and do curls?
>> Oh, 100%, man.
>> Oh my god.
>> I mean,
when you hear that, you know, it's it's,
you know, they're trying to make the
situation, you know, not as, you know,
what it is at, but, you know, to turn
that situation into a humor. It's it's
you know it's it's it's it's a way of
psychologically you know trying to deal
with it to say that you know the rubbles
and you know he's known to be someone
who goes to the gym subhan Allah to make
the most out of it. I'm just putting
myself in this situation cuz I I like to
be active every single day going to the
gym whatever it is for that matter and I
mean I'll probably do the same. You
probably same in that situation. You
just make the best at what you have.
>> My god it's so bro.
Yeah, it's Oh man, this is so it's such
a weird it's I can't believe I'm having
a conversation about this to be honest.
Um because you know we we hear we hear
that you know this is happening this we
hear all these things over here in the
states and it's just interesting to talk
to someone who's actually there. I mean
that's it guys. Subhan Allah. You can
see for yourself when applaud people
like Bradley and many influencers like
himself uh the non-Muslims. Subhan
Allah. As you show it shows that Allah's
mercy, Allah's created all with mercy
and justice. And for those who haven't
lost that, lost their humanity, they are
in their thousands and millions and
billions around the world are showing
the true face of Zionism. They are
standing up to it at whatever cost it
may be. You have non-Muslims who do far
more and sacrifice far more for the
people of Gazas than someone like myself
who's an influencer that could we could
ever do. And that is shameful and may
Allah forgive us for that. Subhan Allah.
And we ask Allahh to guide Bradley
inshallah to Islam. One of the most
beautiful gifts that anyone could ever
ever have inshallah. And that's it guys.
That's what I want to say inshallah. And
go show your support to Bradley
inshallah and donate to the link in the
description brother and sisters uh to
support more people in Gaz inshallah.
Till next time.